okay Maggie Thank You Brady from
recently Northern Virginia just outside
of Washington DC well what brought me to
Los Angeles was treatment every time and
that was in 2013 um
at that time it was alcohol I've been
using drugs since I was I mean well if
you conclude weed and alcohol like 15
but I've been using heroin on and off
since I was 18 I was able to put it down
for about 12 years but I became a raging
alcoholic and crack smoker and so then
in 2014 I was in a horrific motorcycle
accident and a man with cataracts hit me
from behind the irony the stories that I
had offered there 60 days over I'd offer
to go to the bar that night and I chose
to go home and I got hit and thrown from
my motorcycle and help my eyes when I
land on the ground and cars still coming
straight for me
if I if if I had just gotten knocked off
my bike I would had a broken wrist and
some scrapes but I'm lying there in the
car the shortly runs me over with its
front and rear passenger tires like I'm
a speed bump um
luckily I'm blessed because it shattered
my pelvis but a little bit lower we're
gonna paralyze him a little higher
would've been dead you can't even tell
look at me today and my pelvis was
shattered only 9% of the time when the
bones breaking that way if you don't die
on impact they rupture an internal organ
and that didn't happen either but I'm
just I was in 2014 and 2015
like right after that like I see you
like out of the hospital I was like give
me a bottle
[ __ ] this like forget it like forget
sobriety and I was on all kinds of
obvious I mean they had the button and
got everything I mean literally my
pelvis was shattered and that's the term
in the ER report and at this point I was
actually professional Broadway jazz
dancer I danced to the company in
Chicago I've danced with Lion King and
my pelvis didn't heal correctly and so
now I got one thing that's shorter than
the other and the answer is if their
hips are aligned basically their careers
done so that was also another major you
know blow and like I said at this point
I hadn't done heroin and about nine and
a half ten years and I didn't used the
prescription medication but I drank like
a fish and so I came out here to Palm
Springs for treatment and then I got
such an ILP and sober living out here
and I was sober for a year and a half
and after that year and a half I'd had a
bus to James John Hopkins they told me
my pelvis was healed they took out all
the hardware and they were wrong my
pelvis broke away the right side broke
away from the base of my spine and they
took out the bolt if you will the screw
that was pulling that together and so
for a while my right leg was not
attached the rest of my body and I had
to have a fusion at the base of my spine
and the recovery from that surgery was
hellacious I had extreme nerve damage
I had a pool of blood dry under the
incision and that I was having a
scruciating nerve pain going
my leg and there's I mean no amount of
opiates will touch their feet this is
really nothing other than gabapentin and
maybe liriko that touches nerve pain but
this was so excruciating in the surgeon
was like there's nothing wrong something
wrong you know it's just nerve pain the
head of ortho procedures and I I
relapsed after a year and a half sober
my boyfriend was moving all of his stuff
out of our apartment while I was having
a procedure done and they found his
softball-sized mass on my pelvis that no
one had told me about now I never got
angry at God the accident happened
I wasn't literally before the second
tire went over me I said okay God here
we go and not in a like re I'm gonna die
just like you're with me no matter what
and and at this point I was angry I was
distraught why did you save my life to
make it this out what like what you know
I gave glory to God to profess your name
like why why
and so I relapsed I went and googled
literally googled on where to find drugs
in Los Angeles because I hadn't used you
and sent me a MacArthur Park
yeah sneaked up a little bit now yeah
anyway well that then assess my win and
uh it's a lot cleaner now than it was
this was in twenty twenty seventeen
about February 2017 and you know I
relapsed on heroin my drugs of choice
are alcohol heroin and crack and I just
threw it all away I was so emotionally
broken at that
and so since that surgery in 2017
and the fact that I was already and
addict coupled with the fact that I got
a large amount of money because yeah
Jackson was my father
yeah yeah and so a I I relapsed and I
have not been able to to get it back
since 2017 in the past I've had my first
time in treatment was when I was 18 at
the third time with the treatment at 20
years old I got two years over and I've
had and then I've had like nine months
and then that year and a half but since
that surgery I just haven't been able to
get it back got me back chronic pain and
you know we want to do statistic wise
like even lower from equal chronic pain
um not saying that can't be done because
there are people that do it and I got
sober I ended up down in Skid Row about
two years ago for the first time and
like I said I had a lot of money I
didn't have to sell myself for drugs I
didn't have to robbing stealing
everybody but my thing and if I if I
need to I'll pursue yourself because I
can accept responsibility for that
and I'm also not gonna have someone else
try and control me this guy is it when I
like dangle drugs in front of you and
I'd much rather go outing and make it
myself and compromise myself rather than
carbides anyone else I don't know if I
feel like there's some odd integrity in
that for whatever that's worth if it
makes any sense de hey buddy
and so I have plenty jumping all over
the place
so I ended up living down here for three
months and I met a girl that I call my
skimmer Oh angel she was in a situation
where she was being beaten in D to get
out of it and I just did the next right
thing and help someone you know have a
place to stay and said if it's to a this
hotel probably that goes to B if you
need to and I don't think I'd be alive
today down here if it wasn't for and you
know I really got a blessed in that way
but I see Johnny for three months
basically and God God I just did the
next right thing and then I went to
treatment I mean I've been in out of
treatment for the last two and a half
years and but I wasn't done I knew that
I was in town I went because my sister
was absolutely distraught
um she's 50 she's my stepsister
technically her mother died when I was
16 but breast cancer and she since then
has taken on the role of being like a
sister mom and she was tracking me
everywhere I went down here I let me a
let her you know like safety-wise my
stepmother mm-hmm my a little bit
background my parents got divorced when
I was but my dad asked for divorce when
I was like not even like six months old
um he was planning on leaving and then
my mother got pregnant and his father
had done that to his mother so he
thought that it was better to stay until
after the birth and then Esther won um
which uh and so my parents didn't even
have kids was a bit of an accident
I have a brother who's adopted from
Santiago Chile my mother got pregnant
when she was younger before
abortion to illegal and she did what she
had to do and so because of that she
thought that she was born of a game
interested in
came along and so my dad left and he was
I'm half Mexican and there's a Tara had
be called movin yoga she's a womanizer
and in his prime he was a bit of a
womanizer so he was cheating on my
mother was several different women but
then he ultimately married one of them
and that is my sister's mom and she is
basically it's like I almost had two
mothers because my mom will give you a
shirt off her back
she's the most caring woman she's a
retired elementary school principal and
she loves just anybody just off the bat
just because and but as far as her
independence and strength as a woman
that that's not her Forte it's just this
is not and I got that I get my
independence and my strength from my
stepmother so she passed when I was 16
and my sister has kind of been like a
sister mom since then um so I went to
treatment because I couldn't I couldn't
listen to you how I couldn't put is you
got any more but I wasn't done and
and that was May of last year and then I
agree laughs maybe two or three months
after being sober I was on the East
Coast
on at this point and program in
Baltimore and I just I wasn't done and
my parents sent me or I supposed to come
back out here it's where it had some
success and that was in January of this
year and I sat in a program I knew I
wasn't done it still had some money in
the bank and I chose to come back down
here
I remember the hotel I stayed at before
and I lived down here from January until
July in the money ran out well as much
as I sign anyway there's nothing in my
mind I was supportive um and I would
Streetman just like I said I was going
to and this was in July and I was in
treatment for a month and I got about
too much silver and then about a month
ago I couldn't even necessarily tell you
what happened normally when I relapse I
see it coming I see it I know what's
gonna come I understand it I would to
church on Sunday morning a guy had hurt
me really badly right before and I felt
like like this is a guy that took
advantage to be the same guy that left
me when when I was um when I was going
through that procedure and I relapsed he
claims he's got seven years sober but he
stole my medication and like it's just
all messy and him and I began talking
again when I was serving this last time
and he told me that he didn't really
want to be with me you wanna slow things
down and so somebody changed after he
went to propose to me you guys that like
what lowest point now had nothing to do
with it he took such advantage I thought
if he if I if he doesn't even love me if
I'm not even good enough for him below
then what's the point I mean he should
be begging for me to great team with its
residents I know it sounds egotistical
uh-huh but it just it's just really hit
and like I said I went to church
remember some wings afterwards football
was on Buffalo Bob wings I ordered a
beer one beer later I'm back down here
and I mean I could go right back and but
that's what I always do and right now I
feel like I have to take the time to I
can't do the end now I can't disappoint
my family like that anymore I can't do
it to myself it's so demoralizing in the
rooms of a a you're supposed to be
welcoming and they're not always that
way um and I just have to figure out
whether or not I ever gonna want to be
sober or whether I need to figure out a
way to just live my life while I'm doing
this because I'm just not gonna put it
down and be honest with myself um how I
started using in the first place um you
know there's a the suburbs can be just
as messy as the ghetto um we just put on
a better facade uh at five years old my
brother became at Les Deux me adopted
brother
and at this point he had so many mental
he has so many mental issues he's
developmentally about five seven years
behind his actual age which isn't that
big of a deal analogies forty but back
then it was about twelve you know it was
a big deal he wasn't his mother was on
everything under the Sun and 13 years
old and chillin when she during the
fighting gave birth and then
he was in the orphanage for like five
years which is a long time I actually
have a friend from high school who's in
the exact same orphanage as my brother
adopted right at birth and my brother
and it's just it's almost like I need to
give kids opium in the 20s because they
didn't know what's bad for them they
didn't know how to handle his emotional
disorders they didn't and he you know
did the best that they could I guess but
so I was constantly getting blamed for
stuff that he was doing so I was
terrified to say anything you know I
just thought I would get playing him my
parents couldn't fathom that he had this
many issues and so you know I finally
said something and to my mom and yeah
after he ultimately raped me he would
call it tickling I've also seen my
brother we went to pick him up from his
weekend with my mom and he didn't want
to go so he jumped out of the car and my
dad told my mom I don't wait the house
he comes in through the back door with a
big butcher knife gives on top of my mom
on the couch it takes it to her throat
and I was maybe nine years old and I
heard screaming bloody murder I've seen
attempt to kill every member of my
family
he's debited to set my heart on fire
when I was three and
it's uh it's just you know that I didn't
even remember the abuse until I was nice
for the church retreat and the first
time I did heroin I felt like I didn't
have to worry about anything anymore I
didn't have to be the mediator between
my parents so that I can make sure that
I got my needs met so I can make sure
that I have money for the school trip or
this or that because mom didn't talk to
dad dad I'm gonna talk to mom
and and after my stepmother died at when
I was 16 my dad became very selfish
Musil that he'd been a caregiver for so
long he didn't need to learn not to
figure the fact that he's especially a
son and a 16 year old daughter um and so
it's just I I was 18 years old I didn't
even know that you could do heroin any
other way than shooting it I was dating
this guy um and I tried it and it was an
instant love affair and like I said that
was 18 and I dealt with a lot of those
emotional issues and my first couple
treatment centers and I think that's
part of these why I didn't go back to it
even though I did drink and the other
stuff but I didn't go back to that
particular substance and so there's just
then the accident happened and I just
kind of thought okay God you know I kind
of met my quota for a trauma for the
right life you know all right we're good
we got another way okay fine cool um you
know I'm good to go and then the
accident happened and like I said my
pelvis was shattered
now even though that no one was raping
me in that sense it brought up a whole
bunch of it we opened all those wounds
and I mean I didn't I don't know you I
think that you know keeping another car
but my car was gonna you know bring up
some of the abuse everything again I
felt like I was just being reached Rama
ties and so it's you know I had my fair
share of you know think everybody does I
don't like to compare some people I go
my challenge within your trauma traumas
trauma I don't know how you cope or
relate to your trauma and how that
affects you and you don't know how it
affects me something that doesn't affect
me at all my devastate someone else and
I do look at some my compassion as a
blessing out of what happened with my
brother unlike your average mafic doing
a rape abuser where you can just X
amount up your life and everybody hates
them and you know you know dad comes to
the rescue and like you know how dare
they you can't get you can't get rid of
him
you know and uh and you have to figure
out a way to cohabit it and today he's
gay and you know he it's hard for him to
even admit what happened he has he has
his own struggles with alcohol and we
have a very minimal relationship and I'm
able to set boundaries and I just really
don't speak to him um for the most part
my sister my mother I don't speak to my
father while I'm using
I barely talked to my father in last
year I was supposed to meet him at a
baseball game last Labor Day and instead
of hi and I ya know my family's all back
well my sister's in Seattle and the rest
of my family's in Virginia yeah this is
when I was in Baltimore I had like those
few months and I mean they just my
sister says that I'm I'm a good I'm a
drug addict but I'm a good person and
she said that's what makes it so
difficult if you're a horrible person it
gonna be so easy to heat you you know or
to you know be bad at what you're doing
and and I don't even and I don't
necessarily use today because I hate
myself I don't um I'm not entirely
certain why I use I don't know I mean
I've been to 16gb sinners that doesn't
include detoxes and outpatients and you
know I really thought this time like I
was in a great space I didn't I just
didn't see this coming I didn't in that
that's that's what I guess he's got me
so thrown for a loop right now
if it isn't then you just hate yourself
a lot of people here know their
standards are so low that this
environment and frogging - you smell
that works for them because it's where
they subconsciously rest but for you you
know you were a dancer your
very accomplished so for you to be a
very good family
people give me a smart here people view
me as some as a sucker too but um people
I feel like you know I try to do the
next right thing and like maybe if I
wasn't here like there was a woman she's
my mother's age and she she got robbed
if her bag of clothes and everything and
this was back in like March she was
freezing outside of the bank and she
never asked me for drugs there's me
money I think she's asking for
cigarettes and you know I saw her one
night you know I went to my hotel room
and got her blankets everything like
who'd have done that and I kind of feel
good about myself
my struggle is when I get clean they
want us to sit in programs for like the
first year don't do anything don't get
about I can't do that I've been such a
waste of space for so long that I feel
like they really need to look at more of
how they do any like Portugal where they
give people a purpose the offices of
addiction is connection and mm-hmm and
the other the other part of its purpose
you know addicts and alcoholics are such
passionate people and you know we've got
so much to offer we feel and we care so
much that what do we do with all this
actually energy that maybe I think we're
like I don't even give it a crap you
know or how
although that affect you and and my
thing is like I gotta get back in than
doing something but instead it's like I
think that the instrument systems but
they want to keep you in treatment
because they're making money you've got
tree boosters that are paying you to go
they've got G person is where people are
coming in and that worked for the
treatment center behind but she was
there to convinced you to relapse so
that you have to go back to their
treatments in it and then all over again
in the all the insurance money listen
your story and certainly you've been
through a lot so there's that but you
also seem to have the result of never
thought to to do great things in life
there's a lot of these people I've
spoken to kind of just
for multitude of reasons and it almost
seems like what might say you is a great
relationship somebody
I don't know the solution is to that
where you go about finding bad miracles
like that do that you do
is that actually because they're going
to another treatment finding something
to replace your creative outlet
I mean I've got a data center might be
helpful but then in combination with
I would have to agree with that you know
because I do stay sober like when I was
with the guy for you know I had you in
half and like and then when things like
that fall apart you know review which
they do and it's like how I also tend to
in relationships I did a lot of work
online on my mantle just in general
relationships and one of my character
defects is that I won't give him giving
given myself and then expect the other
person to do the same and they don't and
I sacrificed my own knees because I'm
like okay what's my turn to sacrifice
their band yeah I'm gonna need them at
some point and and you know this is just
what you do in relationships and then
time after time I'm not met with the
same with the same loving care and
concern and acceptance that I met them
with and that's that happens in a lot of
my relationships you know I'm not just
romantic but friendship
and so you know that's there's something
I have to look at because I I didn't
realize that I have unrealistic
expectations of people
okay
[Music]
thank you so much for telling your story
thank you and you're very different from
everyone I spelled it to you you don't
look the part and also clearly your
typical skid row yeah